since the phone call and since this
incident my daily life has been anything
but ordinary I would like to say to the
victims and the families and loved ones
of the victims that my heart is with you
and that mainly why I'm doing this is to
hope because I hope to help you in your
healing and it's really difficult you
know it's really difficult because I was
put into the media without my consent in
the first place and I saw this nonsense
that was going on without even knowing
or hearing my truth so if I'm gonna be
put out there I will clarify it and I
will express the truth that I lived the
FBI had simply asked me not to talk
about the conversation that I had with
them and one other thing was that was
his possibility of being homosexual
I don't know why or why not but I really
believe that that is definitely
something to look at because that can
tell us more about him and his reason
for doing it more than instead of
creating other judgements and stories it
was in the moments that he would be you
know angry about something or just had a
fight or pissed that he would make gay
can't continuously make it comment
comments and you know he felt strongly
about homosexuality the impact that this
is going to leave on my life is
definitely permanent but the thing is I
have already been impacted by this
person seven years ago I've been
tortured I've been abused in every way
held hostage and from that I came out
stronger I came out forgiving I came out
letting it go and moving forward with my
life finding my happiness doing what I
love to do I am an artist I like to make
jewelry with beads I like to read I like
to write and do my own artsy stuff every
day and being my zone of meditation and
create healing beauty of course I have
not been able to even be able to get in
a piece of combs
I would also like to share to the Muslim
community the religion into which I
myself am born into that I know what our
religion is about that it's about peace
about compassion about open-heartedness
about family about simplicity that is
what Islam is about and I pray and I do
whatever I can to make anybody that
doesn't see that understand that